[Music]
till now we have been studying
properties of images formed by the
spherical lenses take a moment and go
through the properties one of the
properties of an image is its position
in space from these tables we see that
the position of the image changes as the
object's position changes there is an
equation or formula which gives us the
relation between the objects and the
images position and that formula is what
we call the lens equation let me just
write down this equation first this is
the lens equation 1 over F is equal to 1
over V minus 1 over u in this equation
there are three unknown quantities u
represents the object's distance from
the lens V represents image distance
from the lens and F is the focal length
to understand this let's consider a case
for a convex lens where object is kept
beyond 2 F 1 what will be F here it is
the distance between the optical centre
O and the principal focus of the lens
this distance will be equal to F and
this distance will be U and this would
be V this lens equation is valid for all
spherical lenses as well as for any
position of the object however we can't
use this equation directly there are
some sign conventions that we must
follow before using it and what are
those conventions we follow the
Cartesian sign conventions do you
remember the Cartesian sign conventions
with seen for spherical mirrors here
they are the object is always placed to
the left of the mirror distances are
always measured from the pole distances
to the right are positive and to the
left are negative and distances above
the principal axis are positive and
below it are negative the concept is
similar for lenses for our lens we
assume the optical centre to be the
origin so the first convention we follow
is that we always keep our object to the
left of the origin or the optical centre
can you guess the
in convention ii convention that we
follow is that we measure all the
distances from the optical Center for
instance if we take this point on an
object then the distance of this point
from the lens is measured from the
optical center of the lens like this the
third and the fourth conventions are
easy here they are
I'm sure they're self-explanatory what
does that we measure above and below the
principal axis yes the heights of the
object and the image and what do we
measure to the right and the left of the
optical centre yes the positions of the
object and the image but according to
the first sign convention the object is
always kept to the left of the optical
Center
this means that the objects distance
from the lens will always be negative
but the image distance could be positive
or negative depending on its position
what about the focal length
well the focal length can be measured on
both sides of the lens right isn't it
the same on both the sides which is why
there is a fifth rule that tells us the
sign Convention for the focal length of
a lens for a convex lens focal length is
considered to be positive and it's
considered to be negative for a concave
lens so these were the five sign
conventions that are used for the lens
equation in the next video we will see
some examples based on this equation see
you there
[Music]